Hello there everyone this is my new obi wan kenobi
video for darth vader grogu and ahsoka tano they
finally gave us a look at hayden christensen's
darth vader during the episodes and a lot of you
have been asking about ahsoka and grogu during the
events of the series because they would have been
very active during that period right after order
66. literally grogu would have looked the exact
same because yoda's species ages so slowly and fun
fact too grogu and anakin skywalker or darth vader
however you want to think about him are about
the same age so post all your chosen one memes
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes i will be doing videos for
the series just like i do for all the other
marvel and star wars disney plus series and
i will be talking about the new backstory in canon
that we learned around the order 66 revenge of the
sith era during the book of boba fett so careful
for spoilers if for some reason you didn't watch
any of the boba fett videos but as you can see
from their preview by this time darth vader has
constructed his castle on mustafar when the series
picks up the scene is taking place in a special
regeneration chamber that we saw during rogue
one he uses the back to tank here just like we
saw boba fett using it during the boba fett series
to heal his compounding damage to his body that he
suffered on mustafar while also using that time in
the tank to meditate in the dark side of the force
the whole idea is that the sith tech the sith
armor that he wears his full-on darth vader armor
keeps him from dying like his body was so damaged
that he needs that to live if he takes it off for
even a couple minutes he'll die so all the sith
tech in the back basically just frees him at this
level of damage like it's so much damage that it's
not enough to heal him back to normal his whole
castle on mustafar here is built on dark side
ley lines that run through the planet it's very
powerful in the dark side of the force the giant
spikes on the top aren't just for show they're
like dark side tuning forks that focus dark side
energy into this inner chamber where he meditates
he built the castle using very specific sith
architecture in this specific place all to tap
the extra power to use the force to try and find
padme in the afterlife so to speak find her spirit
and possibly find a way to truly conquer death
as he was talking about during revenge of the
sith and bring her back to the world of the living
so the castle isn't just meant to look badass it
serves a very specific purpose ewan mcgregor also
talked about hayden christensen coming back and
during the clip that i'll post here is him talking
about seeing him as anakin skywalker on set not as
darth vader confirming one of my theories i look
over at him he's anakin now i'm obi-wan now and
it's like nothing had happened like i
didn't see any age on his face i didn't
like the the period of time between episode three
and now just hadn't didn't exist or something it
was so peculiar i think when he talks about seeing
hayden as anakin on set and feeling like no time
had passed he's talking about scenes where obi-wan
is either having visions flashbacks or nightmares
about the past before anakin had turned into darth
vader and started wearing the armor but in the
actual present day of the series this is what
hayden christensen is going to look like he'll
be in full darth vader costume and prosthetics
when he takes the helmet off like we'll see his
face hayden christensen all burned and scarred
like we did at the end of revenge of the sith
so you'll know that it's hayden christensen
inside the armor for those of you asking about
the inquisitors too because they're actually
fairly near to where darth vader's castle is
the fortress inquisitorius is on one of the moons
of mustafar really close by it's the same one that
you saw at the end of jedi fall in order if you
played that game yes it's the same in all the star
wars canon so anytime you see their fortress it's
the same fortress but even though you have all the
inquisitors training over here in this fortress
in darth vader nearby in his castle on mustafar
he himself doesn't really care that much about
the inquisitors they're just a tool to him
he and the grand inquisitor kind of view each
other the way that darth maul and darth vader
would view each other they're like competition
for the emperor just because they're both part
of the empire working on the same team and they're
both powerful dark side force users does not mean
that they're friends just to explain the grand
inquisitor's backstory he actually appears a lot
during star wars rebels the grand inquisitor was
a jedi knight he was one of the temple guardians
at the jedi temple on coruscant he's actually
one of the jedi knights that arrested ahsoka
when she was accused of treason during the clone
wars and had to stand trial the whole event that
caused her to want to leave the jedi order this is
what he looked like before he turned to the dark
side and became the grand inquisitor canonically
they explained that the grand inquisitor was
actually with anakin when they're fighting barris
offi and arrest her for treason and he's meant to
be one of the two guards escorting her into this
giant courtroom where palpatine is overseeing
everything he hears bears off he's big speech
about the corruption the state of the senate the
jedi order it plants the seed in his mind and he
thinks that she's right so later during the events
of the movie when order 66 happens he further
realizes how right she is about the corruption
at least in his mind so it was the beginnings
of his descent to the dark side and he winds up
aiding in order 66 so while anakin is turning to
the dark side becoming minted as darth vader and
executes all these jedi at the temple a version of
that is kind of happening for the grand inquisitor
that was sort of the moment that he turned to
the dark side of the force the producers did
explain that because the obi-wan series is only
10 years after revenge of the sith darth vader
or anakin skywalker however you want to think
about him still in his early 30s still very young
and is incredibly powerful during the events of
the series because a lot of his dark side power
comes from his anger his stronger emotions so 10
years on everything that happened with padme's
death the fall of the jedi is still fairly fresh
in his mind so all of his negative emotions for
that are still very powerful in him by the
time the events of the original trilogy come
around and he learns that luke skywalker is
his son he starts to feel the pull the light
side of the force again it actually kind of
weakens him in the dark side of the forge so
he's actually not quite as powerful as he
is during the events of the obi-wan series
my son it is the only way but i think
because they're trying to be so careful
about not breaking cannon completely with this
obi-wan series darth vader will not learn about
luke and leia during the events of the series they
might tease that like the inquisitors might almost
learn about luke skywalker and leia but obi-wan
kenobi will probably prevent that from happening
also a big reminder too the grand inquisitor
and the fifth brother at least in this series
canonically did not die until the events of star
wars rebels which is about 18 years after the
events of revenge of the sith about eight years
or so after the events of the obi-wan series
so the grand inquisitor and at least the fifth
brother will survive past the end of the obi-wan
series probably get their asses kicked pretty
bad by obi-wan kenobi there's a bunch of red
shirt looking lesser inquisitors in this trailer
they'll probably kill some of them off talking
about grogu and ahsoka during the events of the
series so as we learned during the boba fett
episodes luke skywalker helped grogu unlock his
memories for order 66. would you like to remember
he was saved by these jedi then taken into deep
hiding in the outer rim and grogu himself just
kind of cut himself off from the force used the
jedi technique of just not using the force at
all as a way to prevent the emperor darth vader
the inquisitors from sensing him through the force
he suffered really bad ptsd essentially burying
all his traumatic memories until luke skywalker
helped him recover them and recover his previous
training at the jedi temple because just turning
the timeline here if you think about it grogu same
age as anakin skywalker would have been around 22
when order 66 happened even though he and anakin
skywalker don't seem like they encountered each
other during the night of order 66. grogu would
have been training at the jedi temple on coruscant
for about 18 years by this time jedi are typically
brought to the temple around the age of four that
was about how old obi-wan kenobi was when he was
brought to the jedi temple to become a padawan
so while the obi-wan episodes are happening
grogu is supposed to be deep in the outer rim
somewhere ahsoka tano is basically doing the same
thing during this period just in a very different
part of the outer rim she's doing everything she
can to hide from darth vader and the inquisitors
the only difference though is that unlike
grosgu she's not hiding herself from the
force she's still using the force her
jedi abilities to help people she didn't
cut herself off completely you remember the
ending scene from the clone wars season seven
that's actually a time jump after order 66 a
couple years later the scene of darth vader
finding her lightsaber on this planet with
all the clone trooper helmets is happening
long after the events of order 66 but before the
events of the obi-wan series i know there's been
a lot of talk about them breaking canon during
the series because there's going to be a big
obi-wan kenobi darth vader rematch at some point
during the episodes unless they pull an obi-wan
twist like that for ahsoka's character kind of
bending the rules the interpretation of canon
ahsoka never physically met anakin skywalker
or darth vader again until the events of star
wars rebels during twilight of the apprentice
in the sith temple with their big fight scene
i won't leave you not this time
then you will die probably one of the best star
wars scenes from any star wars production movie or
tv series ever the only thing i'll say about this
is that darth vader and ahsoka did have forced
visions of each other before this moment so that
in flashbacks are the two ways they could have
ahsoka and anakin skywalker scenes but because
hayden christensen supposedly signed a deal to
come back for the ahsoka series in addition to
the obi-wan series i think they'll save most of
the live-action anakin in ahsoka scenes for the
ahsoka episodes for those of you asking about
qui-gon jinn showing up during the obi-wan series
at the end of revenge of the sith yoda literally
tells obi-wan i have a mission for you i'm going
to teach you how to train in the force and commune
with this forced spirit not quite a force
ghost but a fourth spirit of qui-gon jinn
un-tatooine training i have for you an old
friend has learned the path to immortality
qui-gon how to commune with him i will teach you
and qui-gon jinn is going to teach obi-wan kenobi
how to become a force ghost fully like the way you
actually see him during the original trilogy and
then all the other star wars productions so when
darth vader kills him on the death star during a
new hope that's how he's able to become a force
ghost that would be the easy way to explain why
qui-gon jinn would show up during the obi-wan
series i will do more obi-wan videos as we get
more details and footage about the episodes if you
do have any other questions just leave them in the
comments below and i'll cover them in my future
bonus videos everyone click here to re-watch that
obi-wan kenobi trailer a billion more times and
click here for my brand new marvel moon knight
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!